in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for September 3 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Ioannicus, Archbishop and First Patriarch of Serbia, St. Ioannicus was born of devout parents
at Prizren in Serbia.
While still a young man, his character and intellectual ability impressed King Stephen Dushan in the
year's 1331 through 1355, who made him his local fit or personal secretary.
In the year 1377, the Synod of the Serbian Church chose Ioannicus to succeed the Holy
Archbishop Daniel II, though he was still a layman.
His promotion through each degree of priesthood ensured without delay, and he assumed the throne
of St. Sava as Archbishop in the year 1338.
Ioannicus was a good shepherd, zealous for the salvation of his flock, and an ardent defender
of the laws of the church.
He enriched the cathedral of peck with icons and precious vessels.
Taking advantage of the weakness of the Byzantine Empire and of the civil war between John
V. Piliologos and John VI.
Dushan seized all the main cities of Macedonia except Thessalonica, thereby doubling the extent
of his territory.
One after the fall of Setas, he took the title of Emperor of the Serbs and of the Greeks,
and since a patriarch was needed to crown an emperor in view of the sacred character attached
to the imperial dignity in those days, Dushan summoned a Synod of all the Serbian bishops
to Skopje in 1346 in order to elect a patriarch.
The bishops unanimously decided, without reference to Constantinople, to elevate Archbishop
Ioannicus as first patriarch of peck, with the title of Patriarch of the Serbian lands and
of its coasts.
One week later, on Easter day, on the 16th of April, in the year 1346, the emperor Stephen
Dushan was crowned with due solemnity by the new patriarch.
An imperial diet meeting at Skopje, three years later, proclaimed the code of Dushan in which
the juridical bases of the new empire and of the autosophilist Serbian Church was set
forth.
In the Hungarians attacked Serbia in the year 1354, Dushan summoned the aged patriarch
Ioannicus to his side.
On reaching Zecha, the saint fell ill and asked to be taken back to his sea, but he gave
up his soul to God in the course of the journey.
His relics are venerated in the cathedral of peck.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.